je vais vous montrer mon courrier il est
quelquefois pire que ça je le sais
Simone Veil bonjour je vous présente
Florence Belkacem qui va vous
interviewer avec moi est-ce que vous
connaissez nos amis
je les connais par la télévision
et Francis Lalanne que vous avez vu à
Ramatuelle absolument est-ce que devant
vous on peut allumer une cigarette
ça arrive souvent ça arrive souvent ça
arrive souvent et je ne suis pas du tout
une terroriste en la matière ce que je
crois c'est que aujourd'hui il y a tout
de même une campagne contre le tabagisme
et où les médecins ont justement demandé
qu'on évite de fumer à la télévision
alors c'est pas moi qui ça gêne mais
c'est je dirais dans le cadre de cette
action pédagogique que je crois qu'on
peut faire un effort je vais faire un
effort jusqu'à la fin de cette
interviews non je crois que ça donne
vraiment c'est une des choses sur
lesquelles les médecins assistent le
plus c'est l'image qui est donnée à la
télévision justement par des gens comme
vous célèbres qui sont les
idoles des jeunes souvent et bien le
fait le fait de fumer c'est ça donne une
image qui est en réalité très positive
pour le tabac et donc une incitation
d'alcoolisme non plus
le deuxième tour
monsieur bar pour être élu est obligé de
prendre les voix de Le Pen est-ce que
vous lui demanderez de prendre une
position publique je crois que même dès
le premier tour il est tout à fait
souhaitable que toutes les personnalités
candidats aux élections présidentielles
se situent très clairement par rapport
aux idées de Monsieur Le Pen et par
rapport à ce que représente le Front
national cela dit qu'est-ce que ça veut
dire prendre au deuxième tour les voies
de Monsieur Le Pen quand vous votez les
bulletins de vote ne portent pas un
petit sigle qui montre que ce sont des
voix qui viennent de telle ou tel de tel
ou tel type d'électeurs d'abord je suis
convaincu que au premier tour il y a des
gens qui voteront aux extrêmes je dirais
aussi bien d'ailleurs pour Madame
Laguiller par un espèce de vote de qui
d'ailleurs est en soi déjà une façon de
manifester je trouve toujours
préoccupant qu'il y ait des gens qui
choisissent les extrêmes par vote de
refus des candidats je dirais classique
mais vous ne saurez pas vous ne serez
pas on sait très bien qu'aujourd'hui il
y a une grande partie des électeurs de
Monsieur Le Pen qui viennent qui
viennent du Parti communiste ou même du
Parti socialiste et de la gauche toutes
les études qui ont été faites dans les
toutes les études qui ont été faites
dans certaines villes où il y a eu un
fort pourcentage de voir sur les
candidats de Monsieur Le Pen sont des
quartiers où il y avait des voies de
gauche très importantes donc on peut
absolument pas dire il y a tel
pourcentage ou telle voie viennent de
Monsieur le vent ce qui est très
important en revanche c'est de se
démarquer très clairement des surprises
excusez-moi comme tous les les gens
comme tous les hommes politiques de la
droite libérale disons qui disent nous
on fait bien la différence entre Le Pen
et les électeurs de moi je ne dis pas je
fais la différence entre les électeurs
et Monsieur Le Pen absolument pas c'est
pas du tout le discours que je tiens je
dis simplement qu'on ne peut pas savoir
je dis je dis d'abord que c'est vrai
qu'un certain nombre des électeurs n'ont
plus partagent pas tous les les
sentiments et les les idées de Monsieur
Le Pen c'était bien et qui a un grand
parti de rejet et donc il faut bien voir
les raisons de ce de ce rejet ce que je
dis simplement c'est une constat si vous
voulez matériel qui fait qu'au moment où
les gens votent on ne sait pas quel est
le pourcentage ça devient des des bombes
enfin pas barils
c'est que vous n'avez pas le moyen vous
n'avez pas le moyen de savoir si c'est
5%
10%, vous avez un électorat général
on a tenté une expérience hier c'était
la fête le blanc rouge justement parce
que cette question nous importe
c'est-à-dire que un électeur de Le Pen
au premier tour devient un électeur
libéral au deuxième et on a demandé à
notre ami Philippe Guérin ici présent
d'aller hier la fête du Front national à
la fête le blanc rouge pour demander
aux militants du Front non ce qu'il
pense c'est de vous ce qu'il pensait des
gens de la droite etc on va regarder le
sujet on va regarder le sujet je n'aime
pas du tout Simone Veil Simone Veil
aujourd'hui fait beaucoup de flats de de
s'imagrées en ce qui concerne ce que ce
qu'a dit Monsieur Le Pen et Simone Veil
oublie simplement qu'elle est
responsable de la loi sur l'avortement
ce sont des milliers d'enfants de bébés
que l'on tue dans le sein de leur mère
je trouve ça ignoble au Front national
elle n'a pas sa place ici seulement
démocratie Simone Veil a droit à la
parole comme Jean-Marie Le Pen
je n'aime pas du tout Madame Simone Veil
je lui reproche en particulier sa loi
sur l'avortement
qui entraînait le génocide de
centaines de milliers voire de millions
de jeunes Français de petits français et
de futurs qui ne se réaliseront jamais
une femme de gauche
d'une femme de oui de gauche
éventuellement et puis bon elle a passé
difficile à dire
qu'il n'a rien à voir avec Le Pen Simone
Veil bon ben je peux pas trop dire parce
que je la connais pas assez mais enfin
bon on passerez la question sur
n'importe qui je vous dirai non
c'est toujours pareil il y en a qu'un
c'est Le Pen à Simone Veil pour moi
c'est vraiment enfin je dirais c'est
l'abjection politique
c'est vraiment bon je crois que j'aurais
pas de terme pour pour décrire une femme
je pense qu'il y a qui a été d'un
sinisme qui prend des airs de vierge
offensées quand elle parle du Front
National et de tout ce qui pourrait
faire le Front national c'est le diable
je pense quand même qu'il faudrait que
elle réfléchisse un petit peu sur tout
ce qu'elle fait sur les millions de
morts qu'elle a déjà sur la conscience
qu'est-ce que vous pensez de Simone Veil
beaucoup de mal
c'est une femme dangereuse
[Musique]
je reçois du courrier de ce genre
fréquemment et donc ça ne m'apprend
absolument rien si je vous montrais mon
courrier il est quelques fois pire que
ça je le sais est-ce que vous
voulez ce n'est pas que je
dédouane cet électorat pas du tout c'est
pas du tout que je trouve mais c'est pas
parce qu'il m'attaque mais c'est
simplement sur leurs idées quand ils
partent je pense tout de même qu'on a un
petit peu trié là c'est pas
vraies mais devant la caméra c'est resté
exactement comme ce que vous venez de
voir
tout de même qu'il y a une part de
l'électorale
toujours de Monsieur de Monsieur
candidat que vous mais écoutez pour
l'instant je ne soutiens aucun candidat
parce qu'il n'est pas candidat j'ai
simplement dit non je n'ai pas déclaré
alors je suis tout à fait désolée
puisque vous revenez là-dessus avec une
espèce de de certitude j'ai simplement
dit que je suis EDF personne ne l'ignore
je ne cache pas et que je pense il y a
aucun élément à ça et que je trouvais
qu'il fallait que l'UDF est un candidat
aux élections présidentielles parce que
une grande formation politique dans
notre système constitutionnel n'existe
pas si elle n'a pas un candidat aux
élections présidentielles c'est vrai que
je trouve qu'il y a trop d'ambiguïté je
relisais les commentaires qui ont été
faits par une grande partie de la classe
politique au lendemain des déclarations
que j'avais fait sur Dreux et bien
c'était très peu clair mais je crois que
maintenant il est vraiment temps d'être
effectivement la première mais je dois
dire que j'ai été traîné dans la boue
que personne pratiquement ne m'a ne m'as
souhaitée et que les propos tenus ont
été
dans la majorité modérée extrêmement dur
à mon endroit et que le courrier que
j'ai reçu je parlais du courrier le
courrier c'est toujours très intéressant
le courrier que j'ai reçu était aussi
était aussi intéressant alors je me
réjouis de voir que maintenant tout de
même beaucoup ont pris position de façon
beaucoup plus claire mais c'est vrai
vous avez raison c'est vrai qu'il y en a
que qui sont gênés par le déclarations
faire Michel Noir qui a pu faire
monsieur Malhuret comptent faire
d'autres et je crois que on ne peut plus
maintenant c'est ça ne veut et
d'ailleurs je crois que surtout la
classe politique devrait comprendre
qu'elle a tout eu gagné et pour de ne
rien rater de Inna larditube
abonnez-vous et mettez un pouce bleu